time permitting of course inshallah.
Does a person who fasts
um achieve all of these objectives when
he or she is fasting?
>> If a person truly fasts
in the right way with all its
requirements, inshallah he has to
achieve all these objectives. But
when we see around us all of the people
fasting don't achieve these objectives.
Why? Whenever a person does act it has
got two components.
One
is
the method
and second is the objective.
For example,
we human beings we eat.
Why do we eat? The first thing is act of
eating and second thing is why do we
eat? What is objective of eating? As far
as act of eating is concerned, it
contains four parts. One is making the
morsel. Number two is putting in the
mouth. Number three is masticating it.
That's chewing it. Number four is
putting it down the throat.
But the goal, the objective is
to make our health. The objective is to
live. People eat for the health reason
mainly and to live. But along with the
main action there are ancillary things
there are associated things attached
which if it's not done then the
objective will not be achieved.
For example suppose someone takes sand
or sawdust and makes a morsel out of it
puts it in the mouth masticates it and
puts it down the throat. Do you think
he'll achieve the objective? Will he
achieve the health? Will he live?
So there are associated things required
with that. Similarly with fasting
besides abstaining from food, drink and
sex from dawn to sunset. There are other
things required along with it which we
discussed earlier. Things encouraged,
things which are
recommended etc. Abstain from things
which are discouraged to achieve the
main objective.
There may be some people who may do the
right things or there are things for
example the food that you eat it should
be healthy.
If you make a muscle out of a food which
is junk food
which is not hygienic and then if you
have you won't achieve the objective you
won't achieve good health or maybe a
person has healthy food he makes a
muscle out of it puts it in his mouth
mastigates it chews it puts it on the
throat but after some time
he puts his finger in his throat and
vomits out. So will we achieve the
objectives of eating that is health? Not
at all. Similarly to achieve the
objective we have to have the anolate
things besides abstaining from food,
drink and sex, abstain from false
actions, false speech and if you warm it
out the whole purpose is defeated. Let
me give another simple example.
There's a person who comes from the
village to my city of Bombay
and he says that I want to go to
America.
So someone tells him okay purchase a
ticket from Bombay to America and to
reach America
the main
act to go to America you have to
purchase a ticket and go by plane. Very
easy. So the person from the village he
purchased the ticket and he goes at the
airport then they ask him where is your
passport he said what's the passport
people told me I require a ticket I
purchased the ticket they said no you
require a passport he goes back and then
he prepares a passport it takes him few
days few weeks then he comes back again
and they ask him that do you have
immigration clearance what is
immigration clearance some countries
require immigration clearance so he goes
and gets back his immigration cleared
then now he said okay now I have to go
to America
So he has a ticket now. He has a
passport. He has immigration clearance.
And he goes to the counter and he gives
it. So they show him the boarding card.
When he goes to the immigration, they
ask him where is your visa?
Do I require a visa also?
Again, he's stuck. So he goes back and
he applies for a visa. And you know to
get the visa of USA, America is one of
the most difficult. So he applies and he
finally gets it. So how to go to America
is you have to go by plane and you
require a ticket. The main act is you
have to fly in the plane and you have to
purchase a ticket. But associated
ancillary things are that you require a
passport. There should be immigration
clearance. You require a visa. A person
cannot leave the country without having
a passport. A person cannot enter any
country without having a visa of that
country. So all these are associated
things which are understood to a person
who has knowledge. But the basic thing
is purchasing their ticket from Bombay
to USA.
But even after he purchases and has all
these things done for person, if you
compare this to fasting, person abstains
from eating, drinking and sex from dawn
to sunset. But the associated things are
he should abstain from false speech to
acquire the benefit. He should abstain
from false action from all the things
which are haram these ancillary things
and then he will achieve the objective.
Now that person wants to go to America
but what is his objective?
Some people may want to go to America to
study. It's a country where you can get
education. Some people want to go for
sightseeing. Many people they want to go
there for prostitution.
Many people want to go there to have
drugs. Some people do have alcohol. Some
people go there for homosexuality
because America is a country where
homosexuality is legal. So what is the
purpose that you want to go there? Some
people want to go to America to gamble.
So one thing is to go to America. What
is your objective?
So if some people fast
not having the objective, some people
may fast to diet. Some people may fast
to lose weight. So then they will not
achieve all these objectives of tawa,
paradise, forgiveness of sins. They are
fasting. They're abstaining from food
and drink. But the objective is losing
weight. So if person wants to go to
America for prostitution, for adultery,
for gambling, for drinking alcohol, for
drugs, his main other objective won't be
achieved. So what is the objective is
important. Some people may want to go
for education.
So we have to realize that all those
people who truly know
the ancillary associated things along
with fasting and if they know the
objectives which are listed in the first
answer inshallah they have to achieve
all of them. If they don't then as the
beloved prophet Mus wasallam said that
it's mentioned in hadith of the maja had
number 16 90 there are many people who
fast but they do not get any reward
except for hunger and there are many
people who stand up in prayers their
standing is of no benefit no reward
except for sleeplessness
hope this answers the question Dr.
Zakia.